[Music]
i don't know whether it was in the name
of uh victimology
or whether it was in the name of whining
or whether it was in the name of evil
political intent whether it was in the
name of the spread of communism but
somewhere
out there for whatever reason whatever
the motivation was
began this narrative
that is absolutely false
about where wealth comes from
it's a lie
all rich people have inherited their
money
now of course the underlying statement
that that says is that if you don't have
a rich uncle you're screwed
so no need to work hard no need to save
your money no need to invest because the
real method of building wealth is to
inherit money and so the system is
broken and so the rich people should
have all the money taken away from them
and given to the common people is that
it's a very communistic socialistic
underlying message
and the the interesting thing is it's
based on an absolute statistical lie
we did the largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america
my friend tom stanley who passed away a
few years ago his daughter sarah still
does research for the book the
millionaire next door it came out in
1992
30 years
ago
30 years ago
and
you know
and he did a study of 750 millionaires
and he was always criticized for the
sample size john and i have done enough
research and and have studied enough
research
bodies of research to know that 750 is
statistically significant but most
people in the press don't understand
that and people with a political agenda
go well you didn't study real
millionaires he just picked out the 750
you wanted and had confirmation bias and
it just wasn't true it was a solid study
but
we decided to do a similar study 30
years later
and we said hey
we know 750 is statistically significant
but let's do 10 fold let's do 7 500 just
to shut up the whiners
and we got carried away we ended up
studying over 10 000 millionaires here's
what we found 79
of america's millionaires the largest
study ever done airtight research no
confirmation bias research company
looking over our shoulder to make sure
it's right because i knew some of you
would [ __ ] moan and whine when i did it
and so
when we we knew you were going to be out
there we knew you weren't going to like
what we found because we know these
people we work with them every day we
knew who they were
and so anyway what ended up happening
was 79 percent inherited precisely zero
five percent did inherit money but it
was an insignificant amount
like twenty thousand bucks five thousand
bucks something like that which is not
enough mathematically to make you a
millionaire unless you start when you're
one years old and then it still won't
make you a millionaire
so
they didn't inherit enough to become
millionaires or another five percent did
inherit substantial money like a 250 000
inheritance or something like that after
they were already millionaires and so of
course that did not make them
millionaires so 79-0 79 small 79 large
after
or
79 0 5
were small 5 percent large but after
that's 10 plus 79 it's 89. that's 9 out
of 10 of america's millionaires
did not become millionaires because of
an inheritance okay let me let me let me
uh
push on the next question then
so i'm sitting in my sociology class and
i hear that and i say okay so they
didn't get money but they all were able
to pay cash for brain surgery med school
for all these brain surgeons that all
became millionaires
no they actually didn't um
one-third of them 33
of them never made over a hundred
thousand dollars
and so the top the top five professions
were engineer accountant teacher
uh manager
and lawyer doctors didn't even make the
top five
of the professions that we studied and i
was being sarcastic about that but in
the day
this idea that you've well you become a
millionaire you've got to make a million
dollars a year yeah well you get you've
got privilege
right you know you got uh class
privilege or you've got
uh race privilege education privilege
yeah yeah that said you you got a head
start yeah we studied the people we
found they had all kinds of different
starting lines yeah the only thing is
they all had the same finish line yep
and uh all race demographics all age
demographics all regional demographics
we couldn't find anything that said if
you live in this area
or if you are this color you are more
likely
uh
now we did find
whites were more likely statistically uh
on average
uh but
not to where you you could say you know
race is a sufficient blocker the numbers
weren't there
uh plenty of african-americans plenty of
asians plenty of latinos becoming
millionaires it was really not that was
not the correlating thing the
correlating thing was what they did that
they found a system a process and they
followed it